[Music]
may have everyone's attention please we
have a new student what's up kitty are
you trying to make the rest of us feel D
I'm not trying to It's Just Happening
dear God
[Music]
woman get in loser Regina George is a
scum sucking life runer why is he by our
table I can hear you by the way can you
hear me
now
we're going to make her pay girls are
made deranged by what's called hormones
w h o what is going
on don't worry about it dance
[Music]
break pinch
me why is it so tight I mean you've had
it since the sixth grade you're probably
maturing it's funny how a mean girl open
all the doors I've been told y I'm Geor
we as women have to support each other
if you need to talk to me about anything
boy troubles blackheads or alcohol
poisoning I have been through it
[Music]
all Rachel Hamilton builds her inhaler
with vodka oh that's how you use
it slay
Queens slay like no one's watching and
everybody's watching because you're
gorgeous haly fringer it has what's this
Harry NS good
[Music]
Lord